florence is such a talented actor
and she's the real deal
okay you got a plan or should i just
stay dug and cover my plan was to drive
us away
what was it like for you to get the call
and say welcome to the marvel universe
that's crazy
man when it really sunk in was at
comic-con we walked out and i it was
like that's when i was like okay it's
happened
it's happening back together again
how is it walking on a marvel set
compared to all the other ones that
you've been on
there's a lot more security it just
feels big
the big action sequences are enormous
also joining the big marvel universe in
black widow
handmaid's tale star ot phagminlay and
spoiler alert some sparks fly between
him and natasha
okay so tell me where you fit into this
story
and where your character like comes in
well um mason my character is kind of
like a fixer i can get anybody anything
they need
so natasha uses me a lot to get anything
from a safe house to equipment
i said we needed a jet yeah you know
what you didn't give me
time or money we've kind of got a little
bit of a history
you know romantic undertones if you will
and so um
don't do that face you look very like
assistant oh otis got a girlfriend
is there a smooch maybe or is there a
look there are definitely looks
i give it it's it's tough you know when
the person you're into is an
international assassin